they've been pouring out the champagne
in parts of atlanta
in this deeply divided state in this
deeply divided country
the victors have been celebrating the
beginning of a new era
georgians played a pivotal part in
electing joe biden
flipping the state from red to blue
after nearly three decades
and those who helped do that are excited
i'm looking forward to a new
beginning a new administration
i have been so despondent and unhappy
for the last four years
because everything was
everything was a fight and an argument
and so it's time for
us to take care of each other again i'm
just
you know i'm happy it's there's a
there's
precious little happiness lately so yes
i'm very happy thank you for asking
georgia surprised everyone and a lot of
the change was due to the
african-american vote
the expectations now from the new
administration
are huge just been waiting on sniper
went on this day here for five years
and so uh you know it's hopefully gonna
be a good change for us
you know the last four years we have
been kind of
rough out here for a lot of people and
so
i'm really excited about it my whole
kitchen they just been
cheering all day about it i think a lot
of what
trump tapped into is
still there and it's going to be there
for a while
some of that may require us just waiting
for demographic change
in the country i don't know but i do
hope that he can create a big enough
coalition that we keep
the violent white supremacists out of
power in the future
the lingering tensions are writ large at
the state capitol building
with unprecedented security here and at
government buildings
across the country
there are substantial problems and
challenges waiting in joe biden's entry
and a lot of distrust and suspicion
amongst many of his fellow americans
i mean no president is a good president
because i mean
every year getting worse no matter who's
in office so it really doesn't matter i
mean you got homeless people out here
almost dying
and we sought out a few among the
millions on the losing side
who now feel alienated and angry that
was there was an elections board call
and there was a lot of i'll use their
word hate
thrown at republicans last night in this
call
by people that represent our
congresswoman now carolyn bordeaux
uh by people that were her
representative throwing out hate and
throwing out by you know
nice word shade you know but they were
they were being ugly
there are passionate but diverging views
and vastly different emotions
in america now and the biggest job will
be bringing them all together
alex crawford sky news in atlanta
georgia